[Music]
it's the holiday season which for most
of us northern hemisphereians is
associated with winter fun
hot chocolate building snow people
arnold schwarzenegger and jingle all the
way put that cookie down
now and of course being late for work
because of this nonsense
so to keep up with the holiday spirit
what better location to visit in hyrule
than the tropical rainforest of farren
what there's no snow here in
fact i haven't seen a single snowflake
around christmas time for
years global warming man ah
another beautiful snowy day in good old
norway
alright that that doesn't count i mean
norway is basically part of the north
pole right
not really moving on to roundup this
year we'll be taking one final look at
the zonai ruins together with my friend
conrad from the commonwealth realm
in this video we will focus mostly on
the zonai ruins themselves the ones
located close to the spring of courage
meanwhile over on conrad's channel he
will be covering other locations in the
area and its ties to laurellen village
so put on your barbarian outfit grab
your machete and let's venture into the
domain
of the zonai
the farron province is one of my
favorite locations in breath of the wild
and could have been my favorite if not
held back by the absurd amount of rain
plaguing this area
but there's something about a dense
rainforest hiding all kinds of secrets
it reminds me of the tales of british
explorers like percy harrison who in the
early 19th century ventured into the
vast amazon jungles of south america in
search of a lost civilization
which you may or may not know from the
movie the lost city of zee
the city of zee huh that's a funny
coincidence
anyway tucked away inside the vast sea
of trees and vegetation of farren we
find countless of ancient structures
all with the same recognizable building
style of the zonai
repeating themes of serpents or dragons
owls
and boar though we do find identical
ruins in other parts of hyrule some of
which like typhlo ruins are actually
quite large and densely packed
it doesn't compete with the farron
province as a whole when it comes to the
sheer number of structures scattered
around
no kidding i actually ran out of stamps
trying to mark each and every one of
them on the map which is capped at 100
so it's safe to say that there are well
over a hundred buildings hidden around
these parts
despite the fact that almost the entire
province is littered with these ancient
relics from times unknown
only one section of the map is actually
named after this mysterious tribe that
being the zonai ruins located between
pegas woods and harker lake even the
spring of courage which has the largest
and most impressive zonai stoneworks
doesn't belong to the zonai ruins
though it is closely connected to it so
what was the actual purpose of the zonai
ruins and spring of courage in
particular
well to get a better picture of this we
first need to outline where the most
prominent structures are found in fahren
the zonai made a clear effort to mark
the start and end of their territory
indicated by either two pillars or
statues standing side by side the first
of which can be found in the farron
woods to the west of the province
this practically marks the border
letting any wanted or
unwanted visitor to know that they are
now entering the domain of the zona
a similar set of pillars are found on
the other side of the area when exiting
a bar of forest towards lorelei village
after which any trace of the zona stone
works and in between these two border
markers
is where all the zonai action seems to
have taken place
at the northern and southern borders of
the domain are mostly sectioned off by
natural cliff and mountains
looking at the map we see a clear
distinction between three different
areas
almost like districts which all seem to
have served different purposes
the first fork in the road is found
immediately at the border in the fire in
the woods which is the road leading
south into fueral plain however the
zonai didn't build any structures in
this area a plausible reason for this is
that as we can see on the map
the floral plane lies eerily close to
the main of the horse god melania
perhaps the zona wanted to show respect
for divine entities or maybe even
feared it and thus refrained from
crossing into his territory the second
branching path is found at the zona
ruins themselves after exiting pagos
woods
similar to the borders in farron woods
in a bar of forest two large pillars are
placed here as
indications that this is where you enter
the district leading towards the spring
of courage
and finally the last fork in the road is
found right after crossing the saryan
bridge
one road leads south towards martha's
landing after which any trace of the
zonai ends completely this road also
borders guccini plain
multiple so-called zonai towers are
found the other road leads further east
towards lake florida and is marked by
two giant owl statues which again seems
to serve as sort of a border marker to
show that this is where our new district
starts beyond this point we find a lot
of zonai made structures along both
sides of the florian river and even up
on plateaus surrounding florida falls
so there we have it three clearly
distinct districts
all marked by two large pillars or
statues standing on opposite sides of
the road and here is where we find
something rather interesting
each of these districts has their own
dominant building style
for instance the zona ruins area
predominantly houses dragon statues
while the lake floria area barely
features any dragons and instead we find
most of the owl statues here
which in turn are not found anywhere
near the zona ruins
and the guccini plain district features
neither and instead mostly consists of
towers and some stray walls the dragon
district
owl district and tower district if you
will so now let's return our focus to
the zonai ruins and spring of courage
aka the dragon district as the other two
will be thoroughly explored in conrad's
video
one of the most distinctive features
about this area compared to the others
aside from the plethora of dragon
statues is that we find next to no ruins
which look like they may have been used
to house people
we do find these large walls but it's
pretty clear that these were not part of
a larger structure
instead i'm guessing these are retaining
walls retaining walls is a building
technique which was perfected by the
romans and its function is to hold back
the soil and prevent erosion from
swallowing up your territory so they
simply prevent the upper level from
collapsing into the valley below
we find these walls at the spring of
courage too and it doesn't seem like
these walls were connected to some sort
of rooftop of any kind
meaning the whole place was open to the
elements and provided no shelter from
the rain
this in the absence of proper housing
leads me to believe that nobody actually
lived in these parts of the territory
instead it was likely a place purely
devoted to pilgrimage and worship
in a way it's very similar to the great
plateau which was a holy place for the
highlands and where they too
underwent spiritual quests or
pilgrimages to pay respect to their
deity and their ancient ancestors the
big difference being that whereas the
highlands worshiped goddess hylia the
zonai worshiped the dragon spirit farosh
and here is where we need to dive a bit
deeper into the religious aspects of the
zoning the hylians as mentioned before
are all about hylium which as you may
know is a divine being whose essence is
passed on within the royal bloodline
however hylia isn't the highest being in
this universe
she along with the world itself was
created by the three golden goddesses of
power
wisdom and courage then nehru and for
all
the zone eyes seem to have been more
old-school compared to the hylians
instead of worshiping hailia who is
basically but a mere demigod
compared to the goddesses of creation
their devotion was to this original
trinity which is reflected by the three
different statues they constructed all
over their domain
that being the dragon owl and boar
additionally because the zone themselves
were all about bravery
combat skills and magic their attention
was primarily focused on the dragon
serpent farish
who in turn is derived from the goddess
of courage for roar
they did acknowledge the other two
goddesses as well but because the virtue
of courage lay closest to the way of
life
this is by far the most dominant symbol
in their religion
it is highly likely that every zona had
to undergo this pilgrimage at some point
in their life perhaps it was even a test
of strength and courage a way to prove
your worth and officially receive the
title of a zonai warrior the road
leading up to the spring could have been
filled with monsters and traps
hurdles which needed to be overcome and
tested the bravery of every pilgrim
striving to become a strong warrior
finally when they managed to reach the
spring of courage they would pay their
respects to faroush and the ritual was
complete
after this they would receive the
barbarian armor ready to serve the zone
military this is of course speculation
and it could also be that the pilgrimage
towards the spring of courage was more
of a peaceful and spiritual kind
rather than a brutal test of courage
whatever the case may be
it's clear that the zonai valued courage
above anything else
the fact that they are described as
barbarians warlike and savage
doesn't automatically mean that they
were evil on the contrary they seem to
have been very well aware of the
existence of farosh and it's made clear
that the dragon spirits only show
themselves to those who they deem to be
worthy
most people in hyrule are completely
oblivious to them and can just
walk right past them without them
noticing interestingly enough
rumor mill volume 5 titled dragons
actually exist
states that there are multiple
eyewitness accounts across hyrule of
people claiming to have seen the dragons
floating around
here's the kicker though all these
witness accounts come from children
and the article continues to say that
children are pure of heart meaning they
would never lie the fact that only
lincoln youngsters are able to see
farosh
hints that it has something to do with
the purity of one's heart
by that definition the zonai may have
been pure of heart as well
and not the savages they were made out
to be at best they were misunderstood
because of their more primitive
lifestyle but it's clear that the zonai
possessed many talents which rivaled
that of the ancient hylians they were
clearly master stonemasons on par with
that of the hylian stone workers
they had a deep connection with nature
and their deity and the fact that the
ruins of their civilization have
survived the elements all this time
is a true testament to the dominance
they once exerted before
their sudden disappearance and that
wraps up today's video
be sure to head over to commonwealth
realm and check out conrad's video which
goes more in depth into the living
conditions of the zonai their traditions
skills and other interesting stuff found
in the other so-called districts within
farren
and of course a big thanks to conrad for
joining me in this video
as always a massive thanks to my
gracious patreons and channel members
a shout out goes to flavi my latest
patreon to join the cause
thank you so much for your support it
really
really means a lot anyway that is all
for now this is dawn
signing off and have a good one
[Music]
you